Why is Iodine Added to Salt?
Iodine first began being added to salt commercially
in the United States in 1924 by the Morton
Salt Company at the request of the government.
This was done as a response to the fact that
there were certain regions in the U.S., such
as around the Great Lakes and in the Pacific
Northwest, where people weren’t getting
enough iodine in their diets due to it not
being prevalent in the soil in those regions.
Among other problems, this caused many people
to develop goiters (swelling of the thyroid
gland, also sometimes spelled “goitre”).
About 90% of people who develop a goiter do
so because of a lack of iodine in their diets,
so the simple solution was to add iodine to
something pretty much everyone consumes fairly
regularly, namely salt.
This practiced was not thought up by the U.S.,
but was copied from the Swiss who were adding
iodine to salt at this time for the same reason.
This resulted in researchers at the University
of Michigan testing this practice out with
good results and subsequently Morton Salt
Company adopting the practice on a national
level.
This ultimately didn’t cost Morton and the
other salt companies that followed suit much
money, only a few cents per person per year
in iodine, but drastically cut the number
of people who developed goiters in the United
States and beyond as the practice gradually
became adopted throughout much of the developed
world.
Today because most food in developed countries
like the United States often isn’t grown
locally, coming from all over the country
and world, depending on the food item, continuing
to add iodine to salt isn’t strictly necessary.
People in regions where the soil is lacking
in iodine will likely consume plenty of food
from regions where it is not, thus getting
the iodine their bodies need, particularly
because our thyroids don’t need much to
function properly.
For reference, the U.S. Food and Drug Administration
recommends that you consume about 150 micrograms
of iodine per day and, on average, men in
the United States gets about double that amount
per day and women each consume about 210 micrograms
of iodine per day.
Your thyroid itself only needs about 70 micrograms
per day to function properly.
Even though most people get plenty of Iodine
in their diets, because Iodine is so critical
to our bodies functioning properly and the
Tolerable Upper Intake Level is so high (about
1100 micrograms per day, and you won’t take
a fatal dose unless you ingest about 2 million
micrograms, or 2 grams), adding it to salt
is still recommended by many government health
agencies the world over to stave off certain
health problems.
Specifically, Iodine is a critical element
used by your thyroid in being able to synthesize
certain gland secretions which, among other
things, influences your heart, metabolism,
nerve responses, etc.
Further, a lack of iodine during pregnancy
and in the baby’s diet after being born
can cause a myriad of significant health and
developmental problems.
Iodine deficiency has also been linked to
increased difficulty with information processing,
diminished fine motor skills, extreme fatigue,
depression, weight gain, and low basal body
temperatures, among other things.